[Applause]
yeah a maternity we should let not a
dream die as a dream so we want to play
at the Olympics the boys want to play at
the Olympics a Masada mundo I play left
wing on the Zambian actual number on
bottom yes I'll be turning 20 on 18th
October I was born in Mandeville then
you know from there we shifted to Sparta
it's a good compact but it's a compound
those who stay in that compound all
those who struggle it's hard to find
something like to eat shield so it's
kind of hard
I wanted to sport is the way I will make
my life better
I wanted sport to be the way out of
moments I started playing football I was
7 I played football like full four years
nothing was happening I started playing
basketball I played I played them it was
nothing
so after in 2010 one of my friends
enjoyed handball he was like you have to
join this what it's nice I can't play a
sport I don't know what to play they
know that color the coaches are there I
would tissue
after training for two weeks approach
was telling me you're good when I
started playing hand boy I liked so a
path like this this can change my life
[Music]
and boys a team sport that is played by
seven players on court and it's a
combination of netball basketball and a
bit of water polo - one of their Olympic
sports when I was 16 I started playing
for the military team it's time we'll be
having games they would give us
transport money now we keep that trust
with different would walk from McCain to
home to use that money to buy something
I used to buy bread I take them home and
my parents be like wow now I do it I
felt like this is it it's happening now
I'm about to achieve something then one
day I hate that
don't be trouser third Olympic
Development Center I thought good once I
selected the national team because it
feels so good carry your flag in other
countries there the journey of this team
started the five years ago when they are
under 14 this play as the most comes
from the compound we were looking at the
beta heights the physical aspect of
someone our objective is to qualify this
team for 2020 Tokyo Olympics
I was taught that if winds on six
qualified to the qualifiers for the
Olympics
John six it's under 20 international
tournament which is played only the the
southern countries all eyes are on us we
just have to be when I started playing
handball my parents were against it so
they were like no you have to stop this
it would take noise so when I'm going
for trainings have to sneak out my dad
found a job for me I started working but
without him knowing that when I knock
over to it I go for paint one of my
biggest dreams is to play handball out
on Africa make my living through
handball and I know it too hard when
winds on six will have so many doors of
opportunities that would be one of the
Blake
[Music]
if that doesn't happen I don't know I'm
going up and up with a child in the
child needs food it's cold so like when
I come here I don't get anything home so
it's kind of difficult but I just hope
that when winds on six things will
change
you
you
[Music]